all right let's talk about this joe
biden guy uh you know he's been drawing
some crowds suddenly i saw i think he's
in michigan today is he in michigan am i
right uh and uh you know he normally
doesn't draw crowds but now crowds are
showing up and they're chanting let's go
brandon if you don't know what i'm
referring to you should watch our uh
video from yesterday and yeah he is in
michigan there's a big group of people
there and they're chanting let's go
brandon and they have signs and
everything so finally joe biden is
drawing a crowd that's very exciting uh
well anyway the big thing going on uh
with joe at the moment is that he is
really trying to push for this 3.5
trillion dollar spending package now i
was thinking when we were putting this
segment together 3.5 trillion like do
you know how many zeros that is it's an
off what did we figure out it was it's
like 11 how many digits give me how many
digits i think it's 11 or 12 something
like that 3.5 trillion okay it's a lot
of digits
but it's an
unfathomable
unfathomable number okay it's so much
money it's absolutely ridiculous and if
the government was to say we're spending
ten dollars on something but it cost
zero that would also be a lie so they
are just lying to you at the
craziest way 3.5 trillion i'm being told
is 12 zeros that's an awful lot of cash
okay people
but they're pushing this thing and now
of course we know what's happening with
uh kirsten cinema and with joe manchin
they are just under endless assault and
their base is basically stalking them
we're gonna get to that in just a second
but here's joe
explaining
how debt works and you tell me if any of
this makes sense we need to borrow what
when needed
and in that case we're able to borrow
because we always pay our debt we always
pay what we owe we've never failed
that's america
that's who we are
that's what's called for it's called
full faith and credit
of the united states
it's rock solid
it's the best in the world
but here's the deal
there's a cap on what we can borrow
called the debt limit
and only congress can raise or lower
that debt limit
so let me be really clear
this is really important to know
raising the debt limit
is about paying off our old debts
there's nothing to do with any new
spending being considered it has nothing
to do with my plan for infrastructure
or building back better zero
zero
both of which i might add are paid for
so if we're going to make good on what's
already been approved by previous
congresses
and previous presidents and parties we
have to pay for it
social security benefits
american people are promised salaries
for service men and women
benefits for veterans
we're going to have to raise the debt
limit we're going to meet those
obligations
man he's such a liar but i'll give him
the benefit of the doubt here which is
that he's just reading something else
that somebody put in front of him right
so it's he's not even sure exactly what
he's saying uh but i'll even go a little
further than that what he is reading
right there is basically true meaning
that's the way the government works
we're always in debt we borrow more
money to pay off that debt and if we
don't raise that debt ceiling then we
will default that concept is right it
doesn't mean we should be doing it
forever it doesn't mean that it works
does it seem to you guys that this thing
is working right now as inflation is
rising like it's obviously not working
the line though it's all trickery the
way they say things right because the
line where he says raising debt is about
old debt meaning we borrow more money to
pay off the old stuff it's not about the
new stuff it's not about the new stuff
he even says well we're going to pay for
that and by the way the way he's paying
for that is that he's taking money from
corporations and wealthy individuals who
pay most of taxes and by the way do you
think it's possible
and i know you know i'm a nut job i'm a
right-wing freedom extremist do you
think it's possible joe putting aside
debt for a second let's say you get your
3.5 trillion dollars by taxing
corporations and wealthy individuals so
you take money from them to pay for the
stuff that you want let's say you do
that do you think it's possible that
that could have issues that cascade
throughout the economy do you think it's
possible that perhaps those corporations
that you took the money from
may fire people do you think it's
possible that the rich people who
you took the money from may stop
spending as much money and that could
affect the housing market or
virtually any other market because when
rich people have money they usually
spend it and that works throughout the
economy um
i know they don't want to talk about
that but like it might i'm just saying
if you take a 3.5 trillion away from a
certain set of the economy to do
whatever you want with it it might have
you know some effect on the economy uh
but the broader point here is that even
though joe is is not
lying in a traditional sense it's like
he is lying because he knows that
you know that zero the 3.5 trillion
isn't zero he knows that he's using the
language oh it's not new debt it's all
that you know you also pay interest on
debt so it's like it's all lies but the
bigger issue here is how do we get out
of this like if if you're watching this
and you're thinking well wait a minute
um let's say i have a ten thousand
dollar credit card limit i remember when
i was pretty much broke when i was doing
stand-up in new york i was pretty much
broken i got my first credit card and i
think i had a fifteen hundred dollar
limit and i would often hit that limit
and then my credit card would not work
and then i'd have to make a minimum
payment and then uh i would get hit by
interest and sometimes late penalties
and all those things and in essence
that's how you get out of debt because
you start realizing oh i'm being
penalized for this i better not spend
money i don't have i have to act
responsibly right and then i started
doing those things and now i'm very
proud to say not only do i have no
personal debt but i have no company debt
we're running a really beautiful
operation here that's in the black it's
pretty great and then i can employ
people and we can do good things like
it's very cool but instead with the
government what he's saying is well
we've always done it this way the whole
american system is this we borrow money
we don't have any money to pay for it so
we raise the ceiling to borrow more
money
you're not allowed to do that
think about you whatever your credit
card limit is right now if you hit that
limit you can't call the credit card
company
and be like oh could you guys just give
me another credit card so i can pay off
that credit card or could you just raise
the limit on that credit card so what do
we do about this because joe's kind of
right okay this is this is what the full
faith and credit of the united states is
it's all nonsense well yeah okay fine
well we got to figure out a way to not
be doing that that i don't have an
answer for you on this tuesday morning i
will have to think about how we get out
of that maybe it involves some kind of
crypto situation
or at some point
the government would have to do what the
rest of us do which is if i can't afford
it we cannot pay for it and we got to
figure out how to how to pay back what
we owe